So we have an episode up right now
where we talk about a huge feminine issue,
which is toilet seats. Well,
not toilet seats. Toilet.
Toilet etiquette. Yeah,
toilet position. Women out there.
Do you sit on the toilet seat,
you put paper down, toilet paper down and sit.
Or do you hover?
Or do you just never pee? This is a women's health issue.
Yeah, that isn't getting talked about enough.
Yes. So
look at my legs look so weird.
This looks like a little chicken.
They do. They really look so.
I'm impressed. Wait,
do you sit all the way down?
See, this is the hopper.
This is the hopper. But like.
Cause I.
Can you sit like this for a long amount of time?
Are you one of the. Oh my god,
I can't even do that. Oh my god. Wow.
See that? Okay,
tell us about that. Which one are you.
Wait, that's crazy.
Yeah, I just.
But that might because of my boobs?
No, no,
cause I am top heavy. Good thing it's like half of people can.
And half of people. Really?
How? That really hurts.
I feel old. Or incompetent.
Tell us about all of that.